podrían ser declaradas extremistas en el
fondo de lucha contra la corrupción y el
fondo para la protección de los derechos
de los ciudadanos están bajo el
escrutinio de un juez ruso por sus
vínculos con el opositor alexéi navalni
la fiscalía pidió que sean declaradas
extremistas argumentando que entre sus
objetivos está revertir los cimientos
del orden constitucional
las organizaciones alertan de las
implicaciones que podría acarrear esta
decisión de vivir y organizarse que
creemos que las organizaciones que
representamos no rompieron ninguna ley
rusa
entendemos que el objetivo del proceso
no son sólo las organizaciones sino
también la gente que las apoya
una posible decisión que determine que
una organización es extremista tendrá
serias consecuencias
este es un delito grave procesable e
incluso personas que donan dinero a las
organizaciones podrían ser acusadas en
ese momento
[Música]
entretanto todas las actividades de las
oficinas regionales de campaña del
opositor encarcelado fueron suspendidas
lo que generó reprobación desde alemania
el gobierno alemán condena la decisión
del tribunal de moscú basado en la
solicitud de la fiscalía de prohibir las
actividades de las organizaciones de
nava ni por sus fechas de actividad
extremistas
usar leyes antiterroristas contra
opositores políticos rompe por completo
la ley de derecho mixto c's y 50 si
tienen y canadá destruyendo el nuevo
choque entre los opositores y las
autoridades se produce a sólo tres días
de la próxima audiencia de naval de que
se desarrollará el jueves a puertas
cerradas